Caryn's with us in atlanta hi karen
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I think
my call today sure what's up okay well I
was on the way to work today and my car
started to overheat
I took it in to the mechanic and they
informed me that my head gasket was
blown and it would cost about $5,200 I
have a Toyota rav4 2003 and the
approximate value of it is fifty-six
hundred dollars you need a new mechanic
really
yeah head gaskets not head gaskets not
fifty two hundred bucks well it's the
engine replacement which he quoted about
2,600 and then the labor brings it up to
52 in order a blown head gasket unless
you blew the engine did you blow a head
gasket or blow the engine
he said the head gasket is blown but he
recommends replacing me well Betty does
you need a new mechanic okay yeah I'll
help gasket heads gaskets gonna be a few
hundred dollars maybe a thousand maybe
eleven hundred bucks something like that
I don't know depends on the type of car
and so forth that's that's what you do
you don't take a $5,000 car and put a
six thousand dollar engine in it okay
and that was my issue so let's say that
he was wrong and he quoted me the head
gasket but it's really the engine what
would you recommend I do because the car
has a hundred and six thousand miles on
it okay to start with you've got to get
better information from someone else
okay you have to move the car to a
mechanic that is trustworthy and that's
going to tell you what's going on and
what and give you some reasonable
options so we do it's an unreasonable
option to put a $5,000 engine and a
$5,000 car well that's just that
silliness because what you would do
instead let's say your engine is blown
okay the only reasonable suggestion as
far as a repair would be would be a used
engine through a junkyard a salvage yard
to drop into it and that's going to cut
that way down okay that's the only
reasonable suggestion for a repair
that's probably not even going to be
what you want to do though you probably
just going to sell the car with the
blown engine it's probably gonna bring
like seven eight hundred bucks okay at
that point and you're going to spend
whatever money you would have spent on
the repair with that money to buy you
another car for about six seven thousand
dollars why have you got any if you got
the money to fix the car I do I have ten
thousand and saving okay perfect yeah
you're probably buying a car and selling
this one for Salvage if it's a blown
engine but if it's a blown head gasket
you fix the head gasket okay you have to
have the heads machined and in most cars
you can put them back on I mean I don't
I'm not turning a wrench these days so I
don't know the particulars about your
car but I you know this has happened to
me and and I used to turn a wrench in
another generation back before cars
before you had to reboot your car you
know so but just enough enough knowledge
to be dangerous in other words but you
need another you need another opinion
because the guy is at a minimum making a
ridiculous suggestion and at a maximum
is giving you overkill for the repair
when if you can reasonably do the head
gasket that's probably going to be your
route even if you turn around and sell
the car okay if you go because it's so
it's Salvage today but let's say you
spend eleven hundred bucks on it
and now it's worth five thousand again
instead eight hundred that's eleven
hundred well-spent
you follow me exactly I totally agree
then you would take then you might turn
around and still sell the car anyway and
move up a little bit in car but whatever
you do do not take out a car payment and
do not spend $5,000 on a five thousand
dollar car neither one of those things
are going to make sense but I would get
a different giving a different mechanics
opinion on what your options are thanks
for the call